so what are your
thoughts on um the turing test
and the lobner prize which is the
you know one of the most famous attempts
at the test of human intelligence
uh sorry of artificial intelligence by
uh doing a natural language open
dialogue
test that's test that's uh
judged by humans as far as how well the
machine did
so i'm not a fan of the chewing test
itself or any of its variants
for two reasons uh so first of all
it's um
it's really copping out uh
of trying to define and measure
intelligence because it's entirely
outsourcing that to a panel
of human judges and these human judges
they may not themselves have any proper
methodology
definition of intelligence
they may not be reliable so the joint is
already failing
uh one of the core psychometrics
principles which is reliability because
you have biased
uh human judges uh it's also violating
the
the standardization requirement and the
freedom from bias requirement
and so it's really a coup out because
you are outsourcing
everything that matters which is
precisely describing
intelligence and finding a standalone
test
uh um to measure it you're outsourcing
everything to
uh to people so it's really cool and by
the way
uh we should keep in mind that uh when
turing
proposed uh the imitation game it was
not
meaning for the imitation game to be an
actual
uh goal for the field of ai an actual
test of intelligence it was using
it was using the imitation game as a
thought experiment
in a philosophical discussion in his
1950 paper he was trying to argue
that theoretically it should be possible
uh for something very much like the
human mind
indistinguishable from the human mind to
be encoded in ensuring machine
and at the time that was that was you
know
um a very daring idea
it was uh stretching credibility but uh
nowadays i think it's it's very well
accepted that the the mind is an
information processing system and that
you could probably encode it
into a computer so another reason why
i'm not a fan of this type of test is
that
it the incentives that it creates
are incentives that are not conducive
to proper scientific research
if your goal is to trick to convince
a panel of human judges that they're
talking to a human
then you have an incentive to
rely on on tricks and prestigitation
in the same way that let's say you're
doing physics and you want to solve
teleportation
and what if the test that you set out to
pass is you need to convince
a panel of judges that teleportation
took place
and and they're just sitting there and
watching what you're doing
and that is uh uh something that you can
achieve with
you know david copperfield could could
achieve it in his in his show at vegas
right
but is in what he's doing is very
elaborate
but it's not actually it's not
physics it's not making any progress in
our understanding of the universe right
to push back on that it's possible
that's the hope with these kinds of
subjective evaluations
is that it's easier to solve it
generally than it is to
come up with tricks that convince a
large number of judgments that's the
whole
in practice when it turns out that is
very easy to deceive people in the same
way that you know you can you can do
magic
in vegas you can actually very easily
convince people
uh that they're talking to human when
they're actually talking to an algorithm
i just disagree i disagree with that i
think it's easy i
i would i would push it's not easy it's
uh um
it's doable it's very easy because i
wouldn't say it's very easy though we
are biased
like we have theory of mind we are
constantly projecting
emotions intentions yes uh uh
agentness agentness is one of our core
uh innate priors right we are projecting
these things on everything around us
like
if you if you paint uh a smiley on a
rock the rock becomes happy
you know eyes and because we have this
uh extreme bias that permeates
everything everything we see around us
it's actually pretty easy to trick
people
like this it is very short i so totally
disagree with that you brilliantly put
there's a huge
it's a the anthropomorphization that we
naturally do the agentness
of that word is that real word but no
it's not a real word i like it but it's
exactly why it's
useful it's a useful word let's make it
real it's a huge help
but i still think it's really difficult
to convince
if you do like the alexa prize
formulation
where you know you talk for an hour like
there's formulations of the test you can
create where it's very difficult so i
like i like the eric surprise better
because it's more pragmatic it's more
practical
it's actually incentivizing developers
to create something that's useful
yeah as a as as a a human
machine interface so that's slightly
better
than just the imitation so i like your
your
your ideas like a test which hopefully
help us in creating intelligent systems
as a result like if you create a system
that passes it
it'll be useful for creating further
intelligence systems
yes at least yeah i mean i'm just to
kind of
comment i'm a little bit surprised
how little inspiration people draw from
the touring test today
you know the media and the popular press
might write about it every once in a
while
the philosophers might talk about it but
like
most engineers are not really inspired
by it and
i know i know you don't like the turing
test
but uh we'll have this argument another
time you know
i there's something inspiring about it i
think that
as as a philosophical device in a
philosophical discussion i think there
is something very interesting about it i
don't think it is
in practical terms i don't think it's
it's conducive to to progress
and one of the reasons why is that you
know
i think being very human-like being
indistinguishable from a human
is actually the very last step in the
creation of machine intelligence that
the first
ais that will show strong uh
generalization
uh uh in in uh that will actually
uh implement human-like broad cognitive
abilities
they will not actually be able to look
anything
uh like humans human likeness
is the very last step in that process
and so a good test
is a test that points you towards the
first step
on the ladder not towards the top of the
ladder right so to push back on that so
i guess i usually agree with you on most
things i remember you
i think at some point tweeting something
about the turing test not being
being counterproductive or something
like that and i think a lot of very
smart people agree with that
i uh uh
a uh you know a computation speaking not
very smart person
uh disagree with that because i think
there's some magic to the interactivity
interactivity with other humans so to
push to play devil's advocate on your
statement
it's possible that in order to
demonstrate the
the generalization abilities of a system
you have to
show your ability in conversation show
your ability to
adjust adapt to the conversation
through not just like as a standalone
system but through the process
of like the interaction like game
theoretic where
the you're you really are changing the
environment by your actions so
in the arc challenge for example you're
an observer
you can't you can't scare the test into
into changing you can't talk to the test
you can't play with it so there's some
aspect of that interactivity
that becomes highly subjective but it
feels like it could be conducive
to yeah generalization you make a great
point the interactivity
is a very good setting to force the
system to show
adaptation to generalization uh
that said you're at the same time uh
it's not something very scalable
because you rely on human judges it's
not something reliable
because the images may not may not so
you don't like human judges
basically yes and i think so i i love
the idea of interactivity
um i initially wanted an arc test
that had some amount of interactivity
where your score on a task would not be
one or zero if you can solve it or not
but would be the
number of attempts
uh that you can make before you hit the
right solution which
means that now you can start applying
the scientific method
as you solve our tasks that you can
start formulating hypothesis
and and and probing the system to see
whether the
hypothesis is uh the observation will
match they put this or not
it would be amazing if you could also
even higher level than that
measure the quality of your attempts
which of course is impossible but again
that's gets subjective
yes like how good was your thinking like
it's
yeah how efficient was so
one one thing that's interesting about
this notion of scoring you as how many
attempts you need is that
you can start producing tasks that are
way more ambiguous
right right because okay so you can with
the problem with the with the different
attempts you can actually
probe that ambiguity right right
so that's in a sense which yeah so it's
how good
can you uh adapt to the uncertainty
and uh reduce the uncertainty
yes it's half fast with is the
efficiency with which you reduce
uncertainty in in program space exactly
very difficult to come up with that kind
of test though yeah so
i would love to be able to create
something like this in practice
it would be it would be very very
difficult but yes but uh
i mean what you're doing what you've
done with the ark challenge is
uh brilliant i'm also not i'm surprised
that it's not more popular
but i think it's picking up because it's
niche it does its niche
you